so benny and i were both from tesco
retail
um and today we're going to be talking
about how we support a large
organization with its data science
needs um we'll be talking about
um
some of the platform approaches that we
use we're gonna be doing this though at
a very
high level we're not going to be going
into any technologies quite deliberately
um once once we've given a bit of a
platform overview ben is then going to
go into search recommenders use cases
so um
okay so next slide so um what is tesco
so i'm sure that many of you will have
heard of tesco particularly those of you
that are based
um within the uk so tesco we're the uk's
largest
retail organization
uh we operate in a number of other
countries
we are very large we've got
approximately 300 000 people that work
for us
and we have sales revenues in the region
of more than 50 billion
pounds
so a very large organization
so if you drop onto the next slide benny
so this this breadth and scale is really
really interesting from a data science
perspective because
behind the very physical presence of our
supermarkets
we've also got a very large and growing
online retail front
but behind both of these as you can
imagine there's a ton of stuff that
we're having to do from everything from
supply chain dealing with
suppliers
property management
um when people are buying stuff and um
ordering online we've got all the
fulfillment side of things that we've
got to deal with and we're trying to
continuously make this more and more
efficient
so there's a ton of stuff that we're
doing
we're very very broad but also
everything we're doing is is very very
um
at a very large scale so we're hitting
something like a billion api calls per
day
and this can go up to 30 000 apis calls
per second at peak so everything is done
at scale
so um what we have within a data science
engineering perspective though is that
we need to
we we need to be able to build things in
such a way that we can empower lots and
lots of different use cases and do this
in a very very efficient way so if you
go to the next slide benny
so in in any individual data science
project teams are going to be focused on
a particular business goal so this might
be recommenders it might be something to
do with computer vision it might be
something to do with um commodity
trading et cetera many use cases but as
a group as a community
we all have some
several
common goals
so one is that we want to be able to
help data science teams move faster to
be able to build models quicker so
they're going to need the tools and the
data to help them in this process
secondly once they've actually built a
model we're going to want teams to be
able to deploy these models quicker so
we want standard ways of being able to
deploy quicker
then once we've deployed a model we want
to be able to monitor it better more
effectively but also in a way that's
relatively
lightweight and not too cumbersome
so in the next few slides we'll talk
about some of the design considerations
that we have to make within this process
we'll be talking a bit about um infra
some of the components and some of the
considerations that we use and then
benny is going to go into his examples
um but before i go on um i'm just going
to say i don't have anything today on
what the ml life cycle is i've made an
assumption that this this audience here
will be familiar with machine learning
and that machine learning life cycle
but what i will say is that any project
we start with
is always going to start with what's the
business problem that we're trying to
address
there's a standard
ml lifecycle it goes from business
understanding to data acquisition
modeling deploying your model and then
assessing that model in the real world
and maintaining it
but um
that that's the sort of life cycle we
have in ml but actually from an
engineering standpoint one of the first
things we're going to say is where do we
want this solution to be deployed so if
you go on to next slide benny
um
as with
any large organization or most large
organizations today we've got presence
in the cloud
so we're using we're working with many
of the well-known major um cloud vendors
but in addition to this
we have our own private cloud and this
has all sorts of benefits for us in
terms of infrastructure and data
in particular we do a lot of our spark
based etl work
on our private cloud
in addition to this though um
one of the things that's quite
well very interesting in an organization
like ours is our edge compute so um we
have a significant amount of stuff
that's going on actually within store
within warehouse pet tills pdas um
warehouses vans etc so there's a lot of
really really interesting stuff there
but for the take for the sake of today's
talk and because benny's going to be
talking about search recommenders
everything is in that cloud environment
so um if you jump on to the next slide
so that's the way we're doing our
compute um another one that's really
really interesting though is
some of the things that we have to
consider around volume velocity
so
any
machine learning project is likely to
have some phases around data engineering
and feature engineering building the
model and then using that model in
inference
um
as as mentioned in that last slide one
of the first things we need to think
about is um
is understanding that business need
but this is going to then lead to some
really really interesting questions
around
volume and velocity
so for example um how frequently do we
need to rebuild the model um do we need
to rebuild it on a regular basis um what
about when we're running the model do we
run the model say once a week or do we
need to run the model much more
frequently than that
this is going to lead to some
interesting questions such as
do we need to do stream
based processing or can we get away with
batch or do we want some sort of
combination of both alternatively um
what are our consumers going to be
wanting to run the model on demand say
for example for a rest api
um we're then thinking well is it true
big data or can we is it a small data
problem often what we'll find is that
we're starting off doing etl and a b in
a big data type setting so spark um is a
key starting point but actually when it
comes to building models we've been able
to get down to a much more reduced
data set size
um when it comes to building the models
um
can we get away of using cpu do we need
to use gpu
and
finally um
what sort of computer we're going to be
talking about i've mentioned spark
already but um often you know can we use
serverless type compute so there's all
these things that we're having to
consider
when they're doing that early design
but what i'll say is a lot of this is
standard engineering type design work
so um there's some stuff that is much
more specific to the machine learning
world
so if you go to the next slide
so um one of the things that's really
really interesting in in
the world of machine learning at the
moment is is emma lops
and this is a really really exciting
area at the moment um there's lots of
new ideas and tools that are coming
about it's very very fast moving
um i've seen reference to this seminal
eminots paper
presented several times already at the
conference which has been really really
good for me it shows that um
it's the right place
but um
really the general premise
behind ml ops is that while you've got
your ml code which is bit in the orange
there's when you're running
machine learning solutions in a
production environment there's a ton of
stuff that sits around that
so if we move on to the next slide
so
any sort of machine learning solution is
going to look a bit like um what you can
see here
we're going to be bringing in data
we're going to be transforming it we're
going to be extracting features
the features which the data scientists
are going to be looking to identify
they're going to be using these to try
and build their models
um
once they've got a model that they're
happy with they're going to be promoting
it
or deploying it
we're then going to be using it to run
new predictions
but actually
when we're doing things at scale in a
big industrial setting there's a lot
more to it than this sort of simple flow
so i've already mentioned
velocity and volume in terms of two big
two v's that the big data will we've
actually often got to do with another v
and that's the v of variety
so we've got many many data sources that
we potentially are wanting to connect to
so we need to look at stuff around this
um this can be everything from data
catalogs to connectors
ingress frameworks
as we bring stuff in then
how do we validate how do we check the
quality of that data
um and there's ever more stuff more um
other stuff that we want such as do we
need to measure data lineage do you want
to have some sort of data versioning
particularly when you're building your
models
moving into feature engineering um i've
already mentioned that we do a lot of
stuff in spark and the data scientists
are going to be working out what sort of
features they want there's a lot of
other stuff here such as
how we're going to monitor those those
um
models for example for data drift and
feature drift
and um finally we're also looking at um
feature stores so feature stores are
really really useful for managing our
features for sharing our features and
and enabling reuse across models
um
we then get to a model building stage a
lot of stuff that we want to be able to
do here um
one of the cool new things around this
is really automl and um trying to use
algorithmic approaches to optimizing the
hyper parameters that we can select
but then once we've got a model that
we're happy with we've tested it we're
comfortable
um there's multiple ways that we we
might want to deploy that into the real
world so we have different deployment
options single silent a b
uh multi-arm bandits being some of the
common um approaches
and then finally we've got the model
live we're going to want to be able to
monitor it
and basically set up alerts for if we
see anything wrong with without
performing in the real world
so there's a lot of stuff that we really
really want to have in place when we're
running
machine learning solutions in a
production setting and there's a lot of
change going on around these all the
time as new approaches become available
so we're at python conference though so
i wanted to mention python so we go to
the next slide
um
really so
not about 90 percent of the stuff i
think we have is is python uh we have
bits of java and c in places terraform
for obvious reasons
and that really the bulk of what we're
working with at an engineering level is
python
um
i think of course if you're going to a
lot of our favorite python libraries
though there's underlying c plus plus
but python is where the bulk of the
teams are operating
so um as with um
any sort of good
engineering team we have standards
so we have standards and best practices
that teams are encouraged to use
these have the benefit of ensuring that
the engineering that's going live is is
a certain good enough quality
but also by having some of these
standards it means it's much easier for
teams to help one another or for people
from to move from one team to another
because actually they've got that
baseline understanding of what code
looks like
in addition to our standards though
we've also got um
a number of small components that the
teams are able to use and share
and um
so if we if you click again benny
what you'll start to see is that we've
got lots and lots of different
components that teams are able to reuse
and re-utilize so i mean this is
everything from having standard
project templates uh testing frameworks
um a lot of our ci cd stuff has been set
up so it's ready to um
roll onto that next project
and then there's bits of code that are
effectively there to be reused as
templates so things like how we do our
logging
what's important about this
is effectively as mentioned right at the
start
we have a large organization many data
science projects many data science
things going on
by having these standards by having
these templates it means that a new
project comes along a team is very
quickly able to pick up these templates
these standards and get up and running
very efficiently which is really really
key for us
um
so if we go back into the final slide so
as mentioned previously emma lops this
is where a lot of our work is going on
at the moment
what are the emerging standards what are
the emerging approaches around this
and how can we do this um
better we're continuously looking to
improve on things
and um benny is now going to talk about
search and recommendation
because that's one of the use cases that
we've used to drive how we do feature
stores
um just one final word from me and that
is as we're building out all these new
approaches and um
capabilities it's always use case driven
and that's really really important so um
benny i'll let you take over now
thank you very much
yeah so i'll give you a little bit of a
flavor
um one of the use cases here tesco um
which is the the search recommendation
space and um
and hopefully that will
kind of uh
integrate well with what
andrew's just um presented to you and
so the
tesco if you're not familiar with tesco
we're a big supermarket but we also
operate a um an online shopping website
um the grocery tesco grocery home
shopping website
and here we um
um we present the the customer with um
with a list of products in various
different places so for example uh there
are recommendation carousels when you're
on a product page that
recommend products that you might want
to buy next that's a little screenshot
here on the on the right hand side
um
but also there's office uh offer
carousels or there's a search
functionality where you type in a query
and it will then
return a
set of products
um and so
the
the native science team that i work with
um essentially is responsible for
ordering these products that's all we do
we order products basically um
but we do that in lots of uh different
and interesting ways um
so as i've just described there are
multiple different use cases
and each of these use cases has its own
statistical model that returns the
correct
ordering of products
um
but they're trained on
similar input features they're they're
not always the same features but they
they overlap very very very much
um
so kind of to approach that challenge uh
the the other solution is to
uh to use a feature store
um
our feature store is uh spilled on
sparks but it's built on top of the
sparks so when
we say feature store all it effectively
layers is a set of tables in spark so
it's a fancy word for collection of
tables if you will
um
and the con features in
in
our feature store are
either outputs of a data pipeline
uh or a future engineering pipeline or
their um
machine learning models themselves so
i've
visualized a little bit here um that
diagram so you'd have them your
basic data sources so that would be
sales data or click stream data
kind of
raw data sources almost
and then we have a set of feature
creation jobs which will populate
our feature store tables
and then different combinations of these
uh features are then extracted
to train monsters specific to each use
case
um so we will extract those and we'll do
a typical training test split try and
model evaluate the model
and save the model to your repository
and ultimately export to an api
um
and then separately we'll also
extract some of the features
send those same features to the api or
some of them at least so that that data
is available
um
and the api is just like models the is a
quickly specific used case
um just to get into the details a bit
more so this is one
um capability that we have developed
over the last
last year or so it is um uh personalized
search so here
when you type an aquarium
in now search you will
get back results that are um
personalized to you based on your
shopping previous shopping behavior
and the way that we have uh split this
problem up is quite typical of for the
space and also for
the way we
generally approach problems in
this area so we have a candle generation
step where we um reduce the number of
products that we want to order
so we sell about 30 000 products
and um
and here we use uh elasticsearch which
is an open
open source
search tool which essentially does
keyword matching
um to reduce that set down to 72
and we have a feature enrichment
step where we um
collect data for those 72 products so
those are
uh
those can be um features specific to the
product such as the overall popularity
of a product
or specific to the product
i've got five minutes
i'll i'll rush through i'll rush through
it and then we'll do uh we'll do
questions in the in the slack chat i
think because we had some problems thank
you so yeah we had some we have some uh
product query features so those are
essentially the
score that represents the keyword
matching from elastic and then we've got
some
um features that are specific to a user
or the product user interaction so that
would be the blur the user popularity so
how popular
but also um
[Music]
some collaborative filtering scores so
those essentially
identify
similar users to the user in question to
predict what that user might be
interested in
then we use a
fairly simple
neural network to predict where the user
adds a
basket
and that results in some scores those
scores are simply ordered
we return that inference
personalized
list
and that works quite well so you have
two examples this is the unpersonalized
results when you search for biscuits
uh this is
personalized results for one of our
colleagues um you can see that she or he
uh a lot has previously bought um
all the products that have these blue
hearts because it was a part of their
favorites list
and then
our um
our model also thinks that last year he
might like oreos presumably because some
similar users have bought queries before
um that's it um i'll spend the last two
minutes to
to acknowledge well first of all um
andrew's team and and engineers who help
us do things but um i think in return
he wants to acknowledge
all of the data scientists that
that work with the engineering team um
that's a very great collaboration
um i also want to
acknowledge vert slab which is
um a
company in poland
where the majority of our machine
learning engineers work and they are
absolutely fantastic to work with so big
shout to them
last but not least
we're hiring
always really um so you can see there's
a huge
amount of different positions that are
open
um
if you're interested in working with us
it's a fantastic team
for the huge range of different problems
as andrew said in the beginning
get in touch um you can you can email us
at
datasciencetesco.com
or you can email a recruiter
charlottecooper
or or androidme if you want
um
and with that i will close
thank you very much um for your
presentation
thank you everybody who joined and
we're done thank you bye